[Music]
something strange has been happening in
the waters around Spain and Portugal for
the last three years orcas off the coast
of Spain and Portugal have been body
slamming boats chewing off their Rudders
dozens damaged over the past couple of
years raising questions about why the
orcas are doing it in April of 2023 the
people aboard a catamaran near the
Strait of Gibraltar suddenly felt that
their boat had taken a hard hit from a
wave but this was no wave they were
under attack from orcas in just 15
minutes the Pod ripped both Rudders off
the boat forcing The Vessel to limp back
to shore barely functioning
a month later the sailing vessel
Mustique was making a similar Crossing
when for over an hour orcas repeatedly
struck the vessel ripping the boat apart
piece by piece
we are seeing things we are sinking
everyone aboard had to be rescued and
the boat sank while it was being towed
to shore the orcas in this area are
systematically attacking boats
since May of 2020 there have been over
500 instances of orcas interacting with
boats sinking three of them and
disabling many more around the Strait of
Gibraltar which connects the Atlantic
Ocean to the Mediterranean Sea and
recently it seems like the attacks might
be spreading with boaters much further
north reporting attacks it's exactly the
kind of story that makes the perfect
internet meme whether it's indigenous
creators making Orca stickers with the
slogan be a problem money can't solve or
the orcas alongside a sickle and Hammer
proclaiming Eat the Rich it's clear that
the orca attacks have ignited something
in our moment feelings of frustration
over wealth inequality and fears for the
future of the planet due to climate
change and human pollution it's almost
like we want to think that the orcas are
taking revenge on humans for messing up
their pristine Waters
but can orcas actually do Revenge
some Marine Mammal researchers say this
is just another case of
anthropomorphizing maybe we're
projecting because some of us feel like
we as a species deserve it
then again orcas are incredibly
intelligent and highly social creatures
and we know that they can learn and
respond to their environment
so maybe they are trying to send us a
message back off stop invading all of
our habitats clean up your act
but unless we manage to find a way to
directly communicate with the killer
whales we'll never know for sure
but the deeper you dive into Orca
Behavior the more it becomes apparent
that they deeply understand their
environment and will take matters into
their own fins if necessary
for the people whose boats have been
attacked by the orcas it's clear that
the encounters can be incredibly scary
just consider the size of the boats
versus the size of the orcas the
researchers looking at these incidents
say that the average boat that they're
attacking is 12 meters long while a
full-grown Orca can be over 9 meters
long
just imagine being out at Sea Your
Vessel hit repeatedly by a huge creature
with sharp teeth that's known for things
like murdering sharks to eat their
livers and beating baby seals to death
it's happened to Sailors on racing
vessels and even happened to one man
multiple times on different boats since
he works to transport vessels around to
different locations the orcas seem to be
especially fond of attacking the Rudders
which work to steer the boats this
particular population of orcas doing the
attacks is known as the Iberian
subpopulation and it had only 39 members
based on a census from 2011 making them
critically endangered orcas are
incredibly unique in that their
sub-populations around the world can
behave in vastly different ways to one
another but we'll get more into that
shortly
for this particular group researchers
know that they migrate based on the
movement of their favorite prey Atlantic
bluefin tuna and that means they're
often in close contact with human
fissures but the area is also popular
with sailboats because it's the entrance
to the Mediterranean so there are a lot
of recreational vessels too
researchers have even identified one
adult female in particular who seems to
be involved in a large number of the
attacks her name is white Gladys and
scientists speculate that she may have
been injured by fishing gear at some
point and her negative experiences are
thus driving the attacks based on the
scars on the whales of her pod we know
that some of them have had negative
experiences with boats and Nets
the other killer whales who repeatedly
go after sailboats are juveniles and
some scientists think this might be an
example of playful Behavior or sensory
stimulation in different parts of the
world orcas are known to rub themselves
on smooth Pebbles near the shoreline
perhaps because they just enjoy the
sensation maybe it simply feels great to
rub up on a boat and rip it apart like a
dog shreds a dog toy
plus orcas are also aggravated by boats
in plenty of other parts of the world
but have yet to start an attack campaign
anywhere outside of the North Atlantic
but it's not like it never happens
elsewhere there are a handful of
accounts of orcas attacking small
vessels over the past few decades and
even centuries
in 1972 a pot of orcas rammed a family
sailboat called the lucette around the
Galapagos Islands ultimately sinking it
though they didn't attack the life raft
that the family escaped onto but even
further back in time is the story of the
whale ship Essex which was sunk by a
sperm whale when the crew escaped into a
Lifeboat they were then attacked by an
orca that nearly smashed that vessel to
pieces
so what exactly is going on in the minds
of these animals
there are a surprising number of
similarities between orcas and humans
were both apex predators and highly
social mammals who have spread to all
corners of our respective globes for
orcas that means every single ocean and
sea and for humans that means pretty
much all terrestrial land masses and
both species have distinct cultural
groups or in the case of orcas ecotypes
that means in different locations
matrilineal groups of orcas will behave
in distinct ways whether it's in the
type of hunting they do or the foods
that they eat
take the example of the Pacific
Northwest there are multiple Orca
ecotypes in the region some eat mammals
While others eat fish while others still
hunt only in the deep sea they also have
their own distinctive calls markings
body shapes and other behaviors that can
sometimes Verge on the bazaar
in 1987 a female Orca was spotted
wearing a dead salmon around its nose
for whatever reason the surrounding
orcas decided that this was the look for
the season and multiple orcas from the
trendsetters Pod Plus others in the area
started sporting dead fish hats The Fad
only lasted for that summer but it
clearly shows that there can be cultural
sharing within and Beyond orchopods we
also have a history going back Decades
of capturing orcas from the wild and
bringing them into aquariums and many
times they seem to form bonds with the
humans learning from them and from other
captive orcas as if they were making
their own new cultural practices
one example is when orcas captured near
Iceland shared a pool with an orca who
is captured off the coast of Washington
state when human performers worked with
the orcas they noted that the orcas seem
to have coordinated together for how to
behave trainers also saw instances of
dominant orcas receiving fish rewards
from other members of the Pod though
they didn't hear any vocalizations from
the dominant Orca suggesting there was
some kind of communication that happened
earlier
and yet some orcas also have exhibited
aggression towards their trainers from
dragging them underwater to biting them
hard enough to break the bone and
sometimes killing them these seem more
like isolated incidents than patterns
but are these cases of the orcas
fighting back against their captors were
they doing something like what the wild
orcas are doing off the coast of Spain
taking Revenge
foreign
definitively if wild animals are
motivated to take revenge on humans it's
clear that their attacks are becoming
more and more frequent multiple Studies
have found that large carnivore attacks
on humans are becoming more common
partly because humans are expanding into
their territories and partly because
climate change is creating more resource
scarcity and pushing animals beyond
their normal ranges these attacks come
from all sorts of animals in many
different climates polar bears grizzly
bears sub-Saharan lions and mountain
lions in these cases experts don't think
it's so much a case of animals taking
Revenge it's more that they're
encountering humans more frequently than
they ever have in the past
while orcas are also large carnivores
they're not attacking the humans after
they sink the boats there have been no
injuries so far despite the number of
vessels that have encountered these
aggressive pods are there attacks just a
side effect of human vessels coming into
their territory more frequently than in
the past or do they understand something
about the fact that boats carry people
and they're targeting our stuff even if
they're not targeting us
unfortunately there's no clear answer to
this mystery but there is more to the
story of the relationship between humans
and orcas beyond the recent attacks
Beyond Sea World Free Willy or Blackfish
a story that took place in the early
1900s that further illustrates the minds
of orcas their capacity for friendship
with humans and what happens when they
feel betrayed the story of the orcas of
Eden is fascinating and heart-wrenching
and is about how orcas and humans worked
together to hunt off the coast of
Australia for many years never has there
been such an example of orca human
cooperation before or since what drives
two apex predators from entirely
different ecosystems to work together
this story of the orcas of Eden is so
incredible that I made another
full-length video about it that you can
watch now on nebula nebula is a
streaming platform that we built for
exactly this reason to explore topics
more deeply sometimes in new formats and
sometimes within subject areas that
don't exactly fit our main YouTube
channel this video about the orcas of
Eden mixes history with science but it's
a topic I simply could not resist making
a video about nebula allows me to take
risks like this and experiment more
whether it's this historical Orca video
or the nebula original series I made
called becoming human about the
incredible story of how we came to
understand human evolution nebula is a
place for all of its creators to make
experimental and new content like Joe
Scott's Mysteries of the human body
which takes you through some of the most
baffling diseases and epidemics from
history or Wendover Productions
extremities which shows you why and how
people live in Earth's most isolated and
extreme settlements nebula has even
produced a feature your length film
called night of the coconut and a genre
bending award-winning play called the
prince which you can watch in its
entirety on nebula and now if you sign
up with the link below subscribers also
get access to classes you can watch
dozens of in-depth classes of creators
teaching you how to create so if you
sign up using the link below you can
support this channel directly and get
both nebula and nebula classes for 40
off the annual plan for just thirty
dollars for the entire year